there's a cycle
um there's a short-term money credit
debt market economic cycle we call it
the business cycle also and what happens
is you know you go from a recession go
to slow inflation uh is low central
banks uh produce a lot of money and
credit the stimulative it's like creates
that uh credit turns into debt debt that
is something that they has to be paid
back credit is something that's
stimulative it gives buying power so it
starts to create a cycle that goes up it
leads to creating Bubbles and reaching a
point where there's inflation and so on
and through this process the three main
players or three main types of players
are those who are alcohol borrower
debtors is it economic to borrow and be
in debt or lender creditors is it
economic to be uh A lender creditor
and of course there needs to be the same
amount of those because one man's
lending has to be an immense bar link
but you could see how those incentives
are changed by the system because what
they'll put in and at the at the one
part of the system to get it going and
so on real low uh real interest rates
lots of liquidity and so on and during
such times it pays to be a borrower you
know debtor and then in these Cycles
then it goes to the opposite that it
pays to be a creditor so for example now
uh you have a situation where it's
short-term interest rates are relatively
high in relationship to other things
they went from giving money away for
negative real interest rates to to that
they change the incentives the action of
that move from the one to the other in
changing interest rates changes the
value of asset classes because every
asset is a lump sum pay payment for
future cash flow and so the present
value of that with the interest rate has
in effect and there are such things so
that you can watch those they've
repeated over and over again for the
same reasons like this cycle looks like
just another one of those Cycles
essentially we know where we are in the
cycle roughly
um you know you're at the point where
you're approaching the uh late in the
tightening but you haven't yet achieved
that particular goal so you know what
they're going to do blah blah blah blah
blah you know there's a lot of those
things for each investment